two of the most creative playmakers in
the game
who has the best highlights now we're
not talking about the best
nba player we're talking about the best
highlights
alan iverson versus kyrie irving
our categories for today are ankle
breaker game winner
something from nothing which is our
surprisingly great category
tough finish and legend killer this
episode of one on one is presented by
state farm when it comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent for a surprisingly great
rate
stay fun now let me help welcome my
co-host you know this guy very well
nba vet and podcast star quentin
richardson what's up baby
you already know man let's do this i'm
in the building let's get it
all right so this guy that i'm gonna
bring in right now i got a list of
accomplishments hall of famer
nine-time first-team nba defense
nine-time nba all-star nba champion
the glove ladies and gentlemen gary
payton
richard you nailed it baby but next time
you better say
um olympian too man don't oh
let them know let them know you gotta go
i gotta go
but listen you tried to get up too fast
and you slipped again
he told you get up when you get up sit
back down again when you get up sit back
down
watch on your dancing try to put that
hand down and it was all bad
i know he got band-aids all over his
hands man
that's crazy right let's move on to
kyrie irving
oh lord oh oh
take him on now he's playing some good
deep oh no
kyrie should have doused him with some
holy water before this because
his leg gave out because he gave him too
much
i didn't been there before before being
baby
when he when you get hit with too much
your body yo look
look you the glove oh let me speak cause
you see you come from a different
speaking point from this you ain't no
you're a glove man look
i didn't been in this position before
where i didn't try to defend too many
moves at once and
you get to the tents where you bout to
think he's on channels like your body
can't react as many times as fast
as they want to and his thing he just
look look look at kyrie out today
he say i'm the bus driver you on my bus
you another body on the bus
put him on the big stage i don't care
what big stage it is
he shows up and shows completely out
this is in the rookie all-star game
saucing he looking like he had rucker
pork out there look at him
gary i'm gonna start with you you gotta
choose one or the other
who wins this matchup i put it with a.i
man you got you've got to go they are
when they falling down like this man i
see i like it i like it when you're on
your back man
you got your hands again you're trying
to be back up again
hey you feel what i'm saying man see
that right here oh lord that
that's the breakdown right there it's
tough but gary you came at me so hard
after that intro that i'm gonna have to
come against you on this one i'm going
with my man kyrie
i've never seen somebody have somebody
stand on a diving board and do a swan
dive head first
onto the court floor and he finished
with the fade away was that a three or
two it doesn't matter because it was
long
it was a two it was a long time
and did one of these at the end that's
what i love about this show cause it's
really you you know you can't it ain't
no losers
both of these plays are so great and the
players are so elite and so talented
i gotta go with my man hey yeah my o.g
i came in other ai we came in the ice
age we was trying to be
baggy and swaggy but like listen that's
two times he made him get up and
he tried to hurt he sat back down again
on the bb and then he just he
soft laid him like the young boys call
it a filet or a jelly roll now you know
whatever you want to call it however you
want to go
i got to go bubble chuck this round ele
milan
and he butterflied it well done
[Music]
and you know what i really don't even
disagree with that like that's just
you know the one to two it's just
ridiculous
one overtime winner versus lakers in
game one of the finals and oh one
oh my god oh come on now
don't step over it yeah yeah there it is
you only you on the road rose tyler
oh i hate it had to be ut
all right how would has this ever
happened to either of you have you ever
been stepped over like this after
after being crossed over hell no to the
eight you would have been if
this ever happened to me you'd be asking
me what happened to the man who tried to
step over me after this like listen i'm
gonna grab me down i'll be like come
here boy
don't you ever do that don't
disrespectful to me like that that was
that was
listen uh you know what's crazy so i
have seen this clip
a million times right everybody like
this clip i did not realize this was in
overtime
and i also did not realize this was a
game-winner moment that makes this clip
he won the game with this
and this is basically davis lying got
goliath
like basically you know they just have a
chance this game one ain't supposed to
have a chance
right yeah and that's the only game they
won but it was
you know all right here's kyrie
game seven 2016 finals against the
warriors
yeah curry you got to get up a little
closer than that baby
you got to get up a little closer than
that big oh you
oh bingo i i honestly
curry did a good job here like he was
pretty much there right like
christian may i have this dance
[Laughter]
look hey look hey look i'm from chicago
i'm from chicago that boy doing the
cha-cha slide out there right now two
times
this is tough i don't get hot kyrie
takes no
like time whatsoever to set his shot i
just don't understand how he gets it off
like that
and it actually goes in like it looks
like he's just chucking it it's a heck
of a play
this is gonna be a tough one ladies and
gentlemen gary
i'm starting with you again what do you
think i have to go with the clown
you understand me once you hit that jump
shot i'm going with ai again man once
you hit that jake knight
and then you step over somebody man
that's the legendary man
they play this everywhere everybody in
their house play this the kids play this
the babies play this
the nephews play this the uncles the
grandmas
he said hard and then got to get it
got to get out on the ai kyrie what he
did right here it was so much
pressure so much respect in effect you
know
they they they up against the 73 and 9
the the unbelievable golden state
warriors team that they the dynasty that
they are
and were then and this man they cleared
the side of the floor for him say hey
listen
we got we got the best player in the
world lebron james but we gonna give you
the ball and say listen do what you do
we
we we feel like we want you to do this
you got the advantage but at the same
time
i got to give it to bubba chuck this is
this is why
this is why because listen
they were not supposed to win a game and
then this man coming to this game
one they come in and punch em smoove in
the mouth and he put the exclamation on
it with the boo bop
step back huh and then i'm gonna look at
you look down on you and step
over you would like that's one of the
most disrespectful and i love
you my dog my my dog but i hate it had
to be you got to give it to bubba chubby
you shouldn't even say that now cause
it's already over
really need your comment you'll say say
what you want to say man
man about our business baby hey i don't
want again man
hey look listen listen listen not that
it matters
not that it matters i do want to say one
thing
yep kyrie going against that team
that may be one of the best
teams to ever play as a unit first in
all of nba history
ever but are you kidding me and i went
like this
over time over time
are you seriously no competition on this
one
[Music]
all right we're gonna move into our next
category which is nothing to something
it's when something looks like it's
gonna go pretty bad but it
ends up being surprisingly great let's
check out ai first
i miss watching alan iris a man oh my
god that hot stuff he used to do was was
dangerous they took that out
all day long they took that out because
of him
yeah he took it out of the game because
of him he was killing him with that
okay now back up big fella couldn't even
get to
too slow too slow big fella everything
alan iverson did just it was just
like he wasn't even thinking this man
was just moving on the court and getting
to the rim
it looks effortless like ah
yeah that's how creative he was though
man yeah
all day long you know he started trends
and everything tattoos porn rolls
jerseys man he started all the all the
little fab man for the kids man that was
great
arm sleeves all right all that
oh oh i know what this is
oh my goodness yeah this is just a
circus right here
oh this is this is this is the bus
driver oh my god this
this is the he went literally through
the whole team boy the lakers
the lakers getting a lot of disrespect
for the um clips in here man he's
killing everybody
i'm gonna say i refuse to believe that
this clip is real to me
is somebody edited it something
i'm gonna have to start with you gary i
always love to hear what you got to say
to set the tone
he's the bus driver because he was
taking six people to school
even the coach was on the bench looking
at him trying to run over there and hit
him upside down
i'm going bubba chuck on this one man he
uh
that happened he got strings on the
basketball hey
if you seeing me you seeing this you
know how i love you and i rock with you
well he didn't win this category
christian i don't know what you're doing
i don't know what you're doing
man did you see what the kyrie literally
just went through the
entire team the whole team the whole
five that's out there i know you would
have fouled them so you like why didn't
somebody
trip them look at that out the gp
i remember when you tried to trip jason
jason williams white chocolate when he
tried to
buy you you do that you look hey you
ain't gonna do me like this
i trip you i do it you gotta break your
head open man you ain't gonna do it
all right hands down kyrie irving wins
something from nothing category i got it
y'all are right y'all are right kyrie
gets it
i think this is the first category kyrie
won so shout out to kyrie irving for
getting the w on that
oh this against us oh man what's that
what oh that's disrespectful
y'all disrespectful okay um you obsolete
from this you understand you stand on
the outside i don't know if you were
standing next to him or not but he
wasn't in the place
was trying to do this in college and
high school getting called
for violations and it was mj's fault
this was michael's fault
and hey i didn't already told you how
you feel about michael and that's why he
did this and he did it against y'all
that's
that's michael's fault y'all know what
i'm gonna be siding on this one that's
just so disrespectful
yeah you got me in there too godly
that's like a dump on me
all right let's move on to the next clip
kyrie with a reverse against the hawks
here we go oh god oh oh
oh no he might have the best
under the rim layup package ever i don't
know it's the baby
he always on the other side of the rim
look if you try to go get that like
college try to go get that big john
collins too and he clearing stuff out he
wins yeah
look uh oh look at that it's a tough one
right here this is probably the toughest
one of the day right here so far
well see we have two different scenarios
we got ai really no defense
on him he just took advantage of an
opportunity but then we got caught
that's not his
fault christian oh no i don't know
all right let's let's let's do it let's
do it let's put the clips head to head
gary
what do you say you know i gotta go with
the answer
man that's a little man that's almost
five one
getting up your tip dunking on my team
man
coming running in and getting a dunk
like that
and looking like it's easy no no no
just look at that look how high it is
got to give it to kyrie on this one he
was contested
he was going super fast he did the
reverse under the thing with the floater
the english the foul
i'm giving it to my man kyrie come on
man i choose
a.i to break the tie in this
conversation because
ai is all of like unsaid six one that's
over exaggerated he's probably five
eleven six feet maybe
maybe maybe maybe he doing what a six
foot guy inspired him to do in the land
of giants i'm going right there that's
bubble chuck with the stamp of approval
knuckle up on that look that was me
coming in the lane doing that out of the
party and this is the most impressive
part because
he did it like i do this he ain't get
all excited and go crazy i do this
now christian go ahead and announce this
baby
[Music]
goes to allen iverson you all got it
again oh
yeah oh long mj yes sir
uh
don't you be quiet don't you do that
i can't watch mike man mike did the mike
did the what you reaching for he reached
for air when you reach for something
ain't nothing there's like air like nah
i'm not watching i'm not doing nope
i'm telling you right now it doesn't
matter what kyrie does in the next clip
nothing beats this clip i think nothing
listening
when i say the entire hood the
entire chicago the entire america
when this happened this was like this
was the crossover
twice heard around the world i'm not
lying when this side it was like he got
out he came
to i was like what's your boy
when he crossed up him dancing and
looking like no you know how many people
practicing and emulating that crossover
on mj after having
everybody everybody
i'ma say one more time everybody
everybody let's just play kyrie's clip
you could just
play it let's play it just play it
because it's
irrelevant
irrelevant now that's dirty no way
listen that was nasty i remember this
play because that was against lebron
that was after he left and it was big
and you know the difference whatever
they said was between them like listen
that was all that kyrie that was dope
you got over on
lebron and all that like listen oh
whatever
i did to mj this
ain't even close look this ain't even
close
he got michael with the swim put my
specs on man cause y'all just
disrespectful right
i'ma look at it like that that
disrespectful fight you know what i'm
saying i got my glasses on right now i'm
a reason
because it ain't working baby we you
know who won this
don't ask me no more questions hey look
that's young that's young
pre that's pre brave that's pre cornrows
that's look
i'm just trying to get off in this thing
that's young the answer
i'm scared to ask you gary because you
said don't ask you nothing and you put
the glass don't ask me
don't ask me you know who i'm voting for
you just say yo vote christian you could
just say it for the fans because
hey i already won because me and chuck
me and me and me and
both said don't even ask don't even ask
so you could just either say
it's a shutout or is it two to one you
better say it's a shout out this is
this is absolutely positively a shutout
alan iverson crossing over the goat
michael jordan
hands down no competition nothing to
talk about no discussion
he takes over the legend killing the
legend killer category and the entire
one-on-one game head-to-head it's going
to alan iverson and as a philly native i
couldn't be more proud to announce
the winner mr allen iverson gary payton
thank you so much for helping us
with that determination the whole show's
great
y'all seen greatness in effect man both
of these guys are great
but you've seen ai take over with them
them highlights he
took over you know what i'm saying
that's my error baby
my era they talking about era's man this
era one
ai way to represent baby this episode
was brought to you by state farm
like a good neighbor state farm is there
you